monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la direction de bridgestone
annoncé jeudi dernier la fermeture de
son site de béthune plongeant dans la
colère et le désarroi les 8 163 salariés
de cette entreprise
madame la ministre de l'industrie que je
côtoie régulièrement la table des
négociations le sait bien
aucune des options permettant de
continuer l'activité n'a eu de grâce aux
yeux de la direction du groupe qui
pendant toute cette période a joué la
montre manifestants le plus grand mépris
vis-à-vis des salariés des sous
traitants et de leurs familles il est
désormais évident que la fermeture de
l'usiné était cyniquement programmée
depuis des années faute
d'investissements seule comptait la
rentabilité du groupe
bridgestone c'est une parfaite
illustration de ce qu'est la logique
destructrice du libéralisme
sur le terrain les territoires et leurs
élus les régions les départements les
agglomérations se mobilisent et témoigne
d'inventivité pour panser les plaies de
l'exode de nos entreprises à
mais nous ne pouvons que constater
l'absence d'une politique industrielle
nationale solide l'impuissance de
l'europe à nous protéger et en la
matière l'incapacité de la france à
faire bouger les lignes
aujourd'hui ce scénario trop souvent
reproduits dans notre pays au nom d'une
mondialisation dit heureuse ce sont les
salariés de bridgestone comme tant
d'autres qui la subissent
monsieur le premier ministre qu'allez
vous faire pour tenir les engagements
pris vis-à-vis des salariés du groupe de
béthune d'améliorer fortement le plan
social et de trouver des solutions pour
que le site continue à vivre
êtes vous prêt à exiger le remboursement
par le groupe bridgestone des aides
publiques reçues sans conditions ni
contrepartie
quand monsieur le premier ministre allez
vous tirer les leçons de ses échecs et
enfin donner à la france les moyens de
reconquérir cette souveraineté
industrielle que les territoires ont
tant besoin d'offrir à ceux qui
travaillent et créent la richesse de
notre pays
je vous remercie pour vous répondre à la
parole et à madame agnès pannier rues de
chez
maëlys délégué en charge de l'industrie
il avait la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la sénatrice van heghe je sais
combien vous être impliqués comme votre
collègue qui vient de poser une question
sur le même sujet aux côtés des élus du
territoire aux côtés de l'intersyndicale
au côté de la région et de
l'agglomération pour trouver une
solution une solution pour ces huit cent
soixante trois hommes et femmes 863
famille de béthune qui ont été
confrontés à cette décision brutale
alors oui vous avez raison des années de
sous investissement dans l' usine des
années dans lequel on n'a pas non plus
cherché à investir dans les savoir-faire
à monter en compétences à monter le
niveau des investissements explique
cette situation et je peux vous dire que
j'aurais préféré prendre cette situation
il ya cinq ans parce que là on aurait su
faire quelque chose comme ça a été le
cas à bari
aujourd'hui il me semble que nous
pouvons avancer justement grâce aux
outils du plan de relance et à
l'implication des élus du territoire et
de l'intersyndicale avance et en
travaillant sur des options de rebond
professionnels pour l'ensemble des
salariés du site
l'ensemble des salariés du site donc
nous avons nous sommes en train de
recenser les possibilités d'emploi les
possibilités de formation et nous avons
trendy très directement à la direction
de bridgestone que le compte n'y était
pas sur le plan social et vous
connaissez l'implication de ma collègue
elisabeth bornes et de ses équipes sur
ce sujet là nous regardons de manière
très près ce qui est proposé et nous
aurons un observateur dans les
négociations à venir à partir de demain
s'agissant des possibilités de reprise
non seulement nous invitons et nous
avons mis la pression sur bridgestone
pour trouver des solutions des solutions
de reprise mais également nous
travaillons avec business france avec
l'ensemble des équipes de l'état et de
la région et de l'agglomération pour
contacter nous mêmes des repreneurs
potentiels
car si nous voulons construire une
politique industrielle c'est en allant
chercher des solutions c
solution qui nous ont permis de créer de
l'emploi industriel ce qui n'était pas
arrivé
entre 2000 et 2016 en 2017 en 2018 et en
quelques secondes l'oeuvre mais si vous
le souhaitez madame l'ami je vous
rappelle qu'il ya cinq ans c'était
monsieur mac roncq et est aux commandes
il rappelle en tout cas nous sommes en
attente
nous sommes en attendent une véritable
volonté politique et alors nous serons à
vos côtés
merci
[Musique]